what would make you happy coming out of
my mouth right now I'm genuinely curious
I'm not I'm perfectly happy with
everything's coming on mouth and I like
that we spent this time okay Megan
McCain and Seth Meyers get in a heated
exchange on his late-night talk show I
stand by every single thing I've said
and if that makes me unpopular in this
room or in front of you so be it well my
opinions are very strong and I think
sometimes because that is coming across
I do want you to know that the sparring
match was over congresswoman Ilan Omar
who was criticized for her comments
about Israel and a statement that
appeared to not denounce 9/11 Omar
apologized for her remarks while McCain
has continued to be one of the strongest
voices against her the Benjamin he's
bringing up the two tweets that she's
apologized for and I think that's a
little unfair to her especially because
we've established what are you were a
press person no I'm just someone who who
cares about the fact that there's
someone out there who is in a minority
who has had death threats against her
and I think that we should all use the
same language that you're asking her to
be careful about her language and I
would ask everybody else to be careful
about there's someone who did not take
kindly to Meyers questioning was Megan's
husband Ben Dominick in a series of
since deleted tweets he called Seth
Meyers an untalented piece of [ __ ] an
awful person and a monumental I think
that sometimes it's it's see it tends to
be jarring for people to see someone
like me and mainstream news not on Fox
he later took down the tweets and
apologized saying quote I love my wife
I apologize for rage tweeting and how
Seth Meyers treated her I don't like him
I think he's a hack but I shouldn't have
done that I'm sorry to anyone I offended